la maison de l'enfance des yvelines fête
ses 5 ans des bougies soufflées lundi
dernier l'établissement géré par le
conseil départemental est situé à
mantes-la-jolie il est réservé aux
mineurs qui sont confrontés à des
difficultés familiales 58 places
d'accueil pour des enfants qu'ils soient
nourrissons ou jeunes jusqu'à 17 ans ils
sont hébergés en moyenne pendant quatre
mois sur place et les interviews
collectées par patrick jacques de
dixmude et bixente n'a rien senti steban
et parfois les parents sont en
difficulté au point de ne plus pouvoir
prendre en charge leurs enfants au
domicile et donc ils sont accueillis ici
en urgence dans cette maison le temps de
comprendre ce qui se passe dans la
famille et parfois devenir en suppléance
des parents en difficulté si on fait une
moyenne
on arrive on en arrive à répondre aux
besoins de la population à hauteur de
200 enfants par an après le nombre est
important mais ce que ce qui est
extrêmement important dans les rts
exercice là c'est quand on nous appelle
en dix ans on a besoin de vous à 230
reprise on a dit ok c'est possible